Despair and Desperation as bodies are
carried away from the child dormitory
parents have been told that girls were
burnt beyond recognition they have to
wait for DNA test results to identify
their daughters and lay them to rest
but there's anger that measures that
could have saved their children's lives
weren't followed
one door we should have been used for
exit was closed and there was even a bed
blocking that that door
so that's why there are many casualties
the matron tried her best but couldn't
also afford to save many the head
teacher of Salama School for the Blind
says the school wasn't prepared for the
fire
I can I I have to admit that
we do not have
systems like fire extinguishers
because we have always been appealing to
government to provide us with some of
these gadgets
but in vain
dormitory fires are common in Uganda
they've been blamed on faulty wiring or
arson in 2008 19 children were killed in
a nighttime fire at a boarding school in
Kampala
the government said it would Implement
more regulations to prevent tragedies
but more than a decade later families
have woken up to the worst news
Barbara angerpa Al Jazeera